in october of 2019
there was there was a pandemic
simulation called event 201 and i write
about it in the last chapter of the book
an event 201 was a group of people who
simulated a coronavirus pandemic now
remember this is in october of 2019 in
new york city the pierre hotel
and there are a lot of big shots there
and we now know
according to the national security
agency
that coven 19 began circulating on
september 12th damn oh in wuhan that's a
rough month for us across the board
historically then well september 12th um
what happened is the
the and that the satellite
and there was chatter all over the
internet coming out of wun
of people talking about symptoms that
were very much and also cures from the
symptoms
the hospital parking lot the aerial
photograph showed that
it was full
there were three people in the lab who
ended up going to the hospital with
coveted symptoms
the
the chinese government that night at
midnight
went into the lab they
removed 22 000 samples of coronavirus
that were public in the lab and they've
never been seen again
he also took all of the public-facing
um web pages
and they removed
documents and papers about in a function
stuff and we know this is a fact there's
a fact this is what the national
security agency is okay they believe
that september 12th was the day that it
actually began circulating okay
a month later
you have in new york city
bill gates
hosting a coronavirus pandemic
simulation
at that his co-host is avril haynes the
deputy director of the cia
what is the cia doing at a public health
forum they don't do public health they
do coup d'etat
now abrahams is the top spot in america
she is the and she is the one
who hid the torture
the torture tapes from abu ghraib
you know during the cia scandal so that
she now is the head of the national
security agency
tops behind the country she is also in
charge of the coronavirus response
at the simulation you have abraham's you
have people from all the social media
companies
you have people from the pharmaceutical
companies mainly johnson johnson the
biggest one they do and you have another
guy a peculiar guy george gale
who's the head of the chinese
cdc oh man he's not sneaky anybody so
george gale must have known yeah that
this was circulating at that point
by the way any of your listeners who
does not believe what i'm saying can go
and look up event 201 it's still on
youtube
and this was before the
it was after it started circulating but
none of us knew about it okay anyway
before the this is after the nsa had
said that this had occurred the nsa now
says looking back i see this and it
occurs and that's time they didn't know
so then
until around january 3rd so then there
was a big get together of some and
they're all together they're planning
what oh here's how we're going to hand
look around of iris pandemic if it
happens
was founty there no thought she was not
there but there were people from his
agency there so
and the interesting thing is
there was no discussion of public health
they weren't saying how do we gonna get
repurposed medications how were we to
link
11 million doctors front line physicians
around the world on a communication grid
so that we can quickly figure out what's
working you know what's working in
bangladesh what's working in argentina
what are the best protocols what are the
best repurposed medications that seem
effective again right like what's
already working against this type of
thing that we could ask people to get
prepared and get on now to help
themselves well nobody even when it
starts
if a ground of irs pandemic starts
you want to be able to talk to all the
doctors who are treating it around the
world
and find out because there may be a guy
in argentina which there was dr carvalho
who's got good intel who who was giving
i from acting to people
he gave it to 700 frontline healthcare
workers and he gave a placebo to 458
and of the 700 who got it not one of
them got covered of the 400 who didn't
got it 53 percent got covered so he knew
that very early on
but that wasn't being communicated and
if you were fouchy and really wanted to
do a public health response
you'd be connecting all these doctors
and mining what is the best intelligence
what's the best way to treat people and
how do we avoid hospitalizations how do
we avoid tests and you're saying they
were just connecting more of the
business side of it they weren't the
only thing they were doing
was they were saying how do we use a
pandemic
to clamp down totalitarian controls to
essentially
execute a coup d'etat against democracy
how do we get rid of the bill of rights
oh do you think that they brought that
up in this meeting listen i'm not saying
that nobody can should believe me on
anything they should go and do the
research themselves and you go to event
201 and here's what you'll see
the fourth simulation that day it took
breaks there was a total of four the
fourth one is the longest one that whole
simulation is
how do you get the social media
companies
to censor
dissent
and how specifically
do you get them to not talk about the
fact that this was a lab-generated virus
they the george geo says that and this
is what they're talking about for two
hours
this isn't october what was their fear
that if people thought it was a
lab-generated virus at the end they
would start pointing after chinese
blaming not only the chinese but blaming
public health officials who were all
funding you know those studies in wuhan
oh i see
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one